what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down the spoilers for my
academia chapter 332 as the fight
between shiguraki and star stripe
continues
now the way this particular chapter ends
it seems like it could be the end for
one of these two characters and you know
i'm not going to give anything away at
this moment but just know there will
obviously be spoilers in this video if
you watch the channel quite often then
you'll know that i haven't done spoiler
reviews for a few weeks and that was
because i was willing to set up this
whole new camera and get everything
ready i still don't fully understand how
exactly it works but all i know is it's
better quality than my crappy webcam
which i was using before
so yeah it's an upgrade
before we jump into the spoilers though
i should remind you guys that these are
the fan translations and so on sunday
when the officials come out those will
be a lot more accurate i guess they'll
have a lot more details but for now this
is the best we got
okay so the chapter begins with a
flashback of star and stripe in what
appears to be an army training camp the
other cadets were laughing at her for
not being able to increase her physical
capacity and in the narration she talks
about the limits of her new order quirk
she was frustrated that she couldn't
find a rule that would significantly
improve her strength and many people
associated this lack of strength with
the fact she was a woman now this is
pretty interesting because a couple
chapters ago we found out that starring
stripe has a constant rule in herself
that gives her super strength and so you
know what we're seeing this flashback is
kind of a contradiction of that so my
only two explanations are that number
one this flashback took place before she
discovered the rule that she currently
uses to give herself super strength or
number two maybe the rule that she's
using right now doesn't significantly
increase her strength in the way she
wants because as the chapter goes on to
say she wants to reach almight's level
which is virtually impossible
this is directly referenced in the next
line which says that other cadets jokes
that star and stripe is too hard on
herself because she wants to be as
strong as all might but they said they
would always be there to supplement her
shortcomings
back in the present day the
intercontinental missiles that the
americans launched in the last chapter
are said to be on the way one of the
pilots arc star if she'll be able to
touch them and she confirms that she can
but she'll have to give up the laser's
rule to do so
in case you missed the last chapter the
laser's rule is referring to the uh the
rule that she made which combines
several different lasers into just one
giant laser and since then she's been
using it to pin down shigaraki with the
giant aura of air that she made in her
own image yeah this quirk is pretty
crazy i mean the sentence like that
probably would never have been heard uh
until
until she's been introduced to the
series like it's pretty ridiculous
what's going on um but yeah that's what
she can do
anyway she asks the pilots to be the
ones to restrain him when she turns off
this particular rule since once the
lasers are gone there'll be nothing
holding him back
at the same time shigiraki begins to
realize that this laser can't be star's
final attack because there would be no
reason for her to keep on using it even
though she can clearly see it's not
killing him due to his regeneration
the spoilers say that he realizes
something else must be coming and he
decides to go for a gamble
meanwhile up in the sky after doing a
countdown star and strike finally
deactivates the laser and grabs the
intercontinental missiles with a giant
hand made of air that she created in the
last chapter she gives a new order that
says the missiles will rotate but as
she's doing that shigeraki jumps out of
the sea towards the sky with all the
pilots shooting at him simultaneously as
this is happening the missiles complete
one full rotation and the air giant
presses them directly at the spot where
shigeraki is the name of this attack is
state of the art hypersonic
intercontinental cruise punch which is a
mouthful and judging from the full
context of the fight so far and the
conversation that she had with that uh
that guy who looks like the guy from
star wars i feel like this is the single
strongest attack she has to offer
everyone is thrown back because of the
impact of this cruise punch and even
endeavour is able to see the explosion
from japan however shiguraki comes out
of a hole in the ocean floor with his
skin peeled off in a smile on his face i
can't show it in this video but just
looking at the panel is probably the
most horrifying he's ever looked like he
genuinely looks like a decaying zombie
with no skin no nose no hair but due to
his regeneration you know bits and
pieces of him are growing back together
a narration box says that he is now able
to freely control decay and we see a
panel of him from the war arc when he
decided not to decay a part of the
doctor's lab now what this is referring
to is that during the war there was the
moment when shigaraki awakened and
basically destroyed the whole city and
in the lab there was one specific area
that he chose not to decay which was the
area that had a bunch of different
gnomes and we see this later in the war
arc when the gnome was all appeared so
the point is basically that you know
when he decays things it's not random
anymore you know before it was if i
decay something you know it spreads and
it destroys that thing whereas now it's
more like you know if i touch something
i can choose which parts of it i want to
decay which parts i don't want to decay
in this chapter shiguraki explains that
after noticing a stronger attack was
coming from star and stripe and deducing
that new water's limit was two rules he
opened a hole in the ocean floor as soon
as the laser disappeared and he just hid
inside what this means is that the
target that the pilots in star strike
was shooting at well that wasn't
shigaraki it was just a no move that he
sent out as bait but the real sugar he
was hiding seemingly hiding under the
ocean floor as the real shiggy is
jumping into the sky the pilots mobilize
to try and protect star but the nomu
then explodes and breaks their formation
shigaraki then starts to jump from one
jet to another getting closer and closer
to star each time and then he lands on
the lead pilot ship who quickly arcstar
to crush both himself and the villain
with her air giants he thinks that
shigiraki wouldn't be able to survive a
blow that big given his zombie-like
state and so the pilot offers himself as
a sacrifice to guarantee their victory
in case that wasn't clear what the pilot
is saying is basically to crush
shigeraki and himself at the same time
by star using the giant air version of
herself just to crush them and at this
moment she hesitates because she doesn't
want to kill her friend apparently
they've known each other since they were
since they were cadets in the military
training and so shiguraki takes
advantage of that hesitation by leaping
towards starring stripe and grabbing her
face the chapter ends with a shot of him
seemingly about to steal her quirk like
his hand is just fully on her face and i
guess we'll find out next week whether
he's successful or not but like i said
in the intro this could be the end of
star and stripe now is it guaranteed to
be the end of her i wouldn't say so
because there are a few outs that i can
see number one is that in devil was
mentioned in this chapter like he can
see the explosion from wherever he is
right so feasibly he can make it there
in time and justice shiguraki is about
to steal her quirk and never could just
come out of nowhere just punch her out
the way and separate them another way
she can survive is maybe
if at the last second she makes a rule
that her quirk can't be stolen
uh i'm not sure if that would work i
guess it depends on who has the stronger
will like is is shigaraki's will to
steal the quirk stronger than star and
stripes will to keep the quark i guess
that would be a factor i suppose um
but yeah i can't besides those two
options i don't see many ways for her to
get out of this um but let me know what
you guys think in the comments down
below i think the way it's being set up
it's like shigeraki's going to steal her
quirk because
i guess if he doesn't it's like what was
the point of this um
but you guys let me know in the comments
down below what you think thanks for
watching as always and if you haven't
already then drop a like hit that
subscribe button drop a comment do
everything everything it's all good for
the algorithm and until the next one
peace out